[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
reggie miller
joined us in the first hour and he
accused the lakers of treating that game
like it was a pre-season
game bill orem covers the lakers for the
athletic
what do you think of what reggie miller
had to say about that
well they sure played like it was a
preseason game and did not bring the
the requisite intensity you would expect
when you are
on the brink of falling into a hole that
will potentially
you know lead to elimination to the
defending champions and
you know it's always interesting to see
who steps up uh in these situations
vocally and one guy who's become kind of
a leader or a truth teller for this
lakers team is markeith morris
and listening to him last night i mean
you're not going to get it
much straighter than mark keith morris
who said that the lakers
you know this would be the time for
their championship dna to present itself
because they have not played with the
desperation this season that you would
expect
and so you know the truth will be on on
thursday night and frank vogel said the
same thing
you know we will find out how bad we
want this
but i i keep waiting for somebody else
to step up that
that like you know we lebron is not
going to play 40 minutes he's not going
to put up 45.
i i you know dennis schroeder scored
what i scored last night bill
you know kyle kuzma like somebody needs
to step up
i mean is it really that hollow of a
roster that i did i totally overrate
this roster
when i thought they added some new
pieces they might be better than the
team that was in the bubble
well first of all your defense was
invaluable though dan um
but i think we all maybe overrated this
roster a little bit and there's so many
things you can point to
over the course of the season where it's
you know obviously the quick turnaround
and
and the number of new pieces but there
are things montrez harold was unplayable
in the playoffs last year against denver
and the laker he was the crown jewel of
their league of the lakers off season
they gave him nine million dollars it
looked like a steal
he can't get on the court in this series
so what was the value of that addition
if it's not somebody who can help you in
the playoffs
marc gasol heralded edition you go out
and sign his replacement while he's
dealing with covid so not a lot of trust
there
and like you said dennis schruter not
playing well so the lakers
they made splashy moves but here we are
with the season on the line and those
players
are not are not contributing in a
meaningful way and so
i i don't know quite how you unpack this
season just yet
you could certainly point to the injury
for anthony davis i mean it is obviously
a massive blow
but you kind of have to look at this
moment as more of a culmination of
a series of of obstacles over the course
of the season
and and the moments that the lakers had
where you would have expected them to
start looking like a champion and it
hasn't happened
you know from the from the roster moves
to the um to some of the
kind of bewildering losses along the way
to the parent you know kind of apathy
at times i just i i just think this team
has never looked like
the best team in the nba and we've sort
of given them the credit
of being last year's champion and
dominating in the bubble where they were
so tremendous
but we haven't seen that team again this
year we had chris bosh on last hour and
chris
suffered the same injury similar injury
that a.d has
and he said he doesn't think you'll see
anthony davis
the rest of the the postseason even if
the lakers advance
um how serious are the are the lakers
letting on that this is a serious injury
or
can one day two days three days of rest
help him play in game six i think i
think the real answer is that we don't
know because the lakers have one small
advantage and it's that
only they know and so they can at least
force phoenix to prepare for
anthony davis even if he's not going to
play and it was a little bit of you know
game of cat and mouse going into game
five where the lakers said he's going to
be
he's going to be a game time decision a
game time decision and i sat my butt in
that arena
two and a half hours before the game and
watched him come on the court and he
you know did maybe the lightest pregame
workout i've ever seen you know a few
light jumpers a couple step backs
you know nothing that indicated he was
actually trying to get ready for the for
to play in an nba game let alone a
playoff game
and after the game when we asked dennis
schruter like oh how disappointing was
it that a.d wasn't able to go he's like
oh we already knew
we knew he wasn't gonna be able to play
so i do think there is a little bit of
gamesmanship going on with this injury
i think the hope would be that you know
you get him four days off between games
four and six and
he's able to at least give it a go and
you know he played through a sprained
knee
in game four um you know anthony davis
has a certain reputation when it comes
to injuries but he's shown a willingness
to try to play through pain
particularly this postseason but you
know a groin injury and
you know you only need to go back to
lebron james two years ago
to to remember how devastating this can
be to a team's chances the lakers went
from fourth in the west
to being out of the playoffs because
lebron missed a quarter of the season
with
with what ended up being a torn groin
and this doesn't sound as severe but
um in a in a short period of time and in
when one game is the difference in your
season it could be just as crippling
what do you think of the nickname that
barkley bestowed upon anthony davis
was that was that uh street clothes
davis yeah
a little a little mean but i mean yeah i
mean
i mean but i do i do think you know i
mean
anthony davis had a reputation as a
player who was injured a lot before he
came from new orleans
and um really i think was bucking that
last year where he
you know was really healthy a year ago
and it was so good in the bubble i think
it was it's a new chapter for him and
he's obviously the beginning of his
lakers
you know journey for he's going to start
your first year of a five-year
max contract but i mean he has to be on
the floor for the lakers to
reap the benefits of what he brings
because when he's healthy he's one of
the most you know
supremely and diversely talented players
in the league
um but but he goes down a lot he looks
hurt a lot and this year
those injuries have turned out to be
real a lot
did anybody ask lebron why he left early
lebron had a very brief media session
last night i would say frank vogel's
answer to that was
just that he yo needs to get his
treatment um
and you know preparing for a game six i
think you know this is something we've
seen from lebron a couple of times
and there is i think no doubt an element
of frustration you know he's watching
alfonzo mckinney and ben mclemore heaved
bricks in a 30-point loss
um in in a playoff game and he's not
getting any help
and but also i mean this is a guy who is
36
dealing with a sprained ankle um you
know he has never missed a playoff game
in his career
and there's a quick turnaround to game
six and you know a flight back to los
angeles um you know i think there is
probably
if we if if we put the pitchforks down
just a little bit you know a little bit
you can understand that the need for him
to get you know to get on the training
table that's probably more important
than him being
supportive of ben mclemore and alfonso
mckinney but the optics i agree are
always bad but we've seen it from him
before
we've seen it over in the last month
even where the lakers are
are getting are getting run out of the
building and he gets up and just heads
back starts treatment early
what do you think happens in game six
i i think they could lose i really think
this could be the end of
the end of their season because i need
them to prove that they
that they want this that they are
interested in in what the challenge of
being
you know repeat champions looks like you
know the lakers last night did not look
interested they did not look like a team
that has any interest in getting back on
a plane and coming to phoenix
they have not looked like a team with a
great deal of belief in themselves
dating back to their loss early in may
to the toronto raptors which was kind of
the low point of the season lebron
re-aggravated his ankle
kyle kuzma said you know we're just not
good enough you know they've had
they've trended upwards since that
moment but here they are getting kind of
smacked back down
against to a higher c the team that is
playing like a team
and i don't know that the lakers have i
think the onus is obviously on the
lakers they trail 3-2
to prove that this is something they can
do or they even want to do because i
have not seen
many signs from this team that they
believe that they have any business uh
viewing themselves as championship
contenders anymore
do they just run it back if next year if
they bow out here in the first round
or will there be any kind of seismic
changes here bill
i mean rob palinka overhauled the roster
that won a championship i have a hard
time imagining him standing pat with the
team that flames out in the first round
if that's indeed what happens
there are some big decisions though i
mean dennis schroeder who you mentioned
earlier
um has in my mind cost himself a lot of
money in the in these
in these playoffs i mean this is a guy
who turned down an 84 million dollar
contract extension
um which i think is a huge turning point
this season by the way when the lakers
turned around and said okay
you don't want to sign a contract
extension we'll trade you toronto for
kyle valerie
a deal that almost happened um and i
think in hindsight
would have benefited the lakers at this
point um you know
does dennis schruter view himself
differently does he come back to the
bargaining table
or does he go somewhere else and try to
you know find a one-year deal to get
himself
where he wants to be i'm not sure the
lakers view him as a 17
million dollar player anymore um so
that's that's gonna be a huge question
mantras harold has a player option
they have big questions at the center
position i don't think andre drummond or
marc gasol is the answer there
i think there's a lot of changes you
would want to make to the roster but
you're also locked into a lot of these
guys montrezl probably not going to opt
out of 9 million
kcp is probably here to stay and alex
caruso who's
you know one of the best values in the
nba is going to be an unrestricted free
agent and highly sought after so i think
there's a lot of potential for this
roster to change
but you do have the benefit of knowing
that you have lebron james and anthony
davis locked in and when they're healthy
that is that is enough to at least
contend is the city of los angeles ready
for
a moment where the lakers aren't in the
postseason and the clippers
are i don't think the city of los
angeles cares what the clippers do
it is the 40th straight year in which
that is the case the clippers have
and listen i like i i i like
i like the clippers i like i like i like
their story i like what they they have
you know obviously you know you would
love to see the lakers clippers
playoff series eventually but in terms
of like you know my day-to-day at the
grocery store or dropping my kids off at
the montessori school in redondo beach
each morning
no one is sitting around like going oh
man i've got clippers fever
it has never happened i i don't know i
don't know how many championships the
clippers would have to win before
um it would it would permeate just like
my bubble but
the lakers as as you know we always as
we always say you know the lakers
uh you know the clippers could win the
championship and the headline the next
day would be
why didn't the lakers win the
championship
still a little drama left to be written
here but uh
you got an easy job bill i mean you
always got a storyline right
i mean it is it is certainly true with
these guys it's one thing it's one thing
or another
um you know they are the biggest story
in the nba well it's the benefit of
covering lebron james um
but it might be the biggest story of the
nba offseason pretty quickly
thank you bill we appreciate your time
as always thank you dan appreciate it
that's uh bill orm he covers the lakers
for the athletic